- Anything I can answer for you?
- I was just curious
what's going on in your life?
- Not much.
(Gary and Jocelyn laughing)
- Not really.
- Vayner.
Vayner.
My day's just filled
with headaches and I'm just
trying to like I really
meant what I just said to you.
I work for you.
- [Jocelyn] Mhmmm.
- I don't know what
else to tell you.
When you take on the
responsibility to be the last
line of defense,
it's all your fault.
All of it.
- [Jocelyn] Mhmmm.
- And so, I feel a huge
gratitude in everybody's trust
and a huge sense responsibly
to deliver for everybody like
I think we're really building
something for real like
not just lip service.
It's just very black-and-white
to me, I know we are and I want
to see it through and I want to
really deliver so I feel like
public, great pressure.
- [Jocelyn] That's a lot.
- You know?
It's just five offices,
800 people almost now.
Not to mention all, you know
just like all the other stuff
that goes along with like my
life, like the content and the
books and the speaking and being
pulled in a million directions,
it is a lot but
like I made my bed.
I can't complain about
sleeping in it, you know?
- [Jocelyn] Yeah.
- And then let's really get to
the punchline, in the world of
8 billion people
I'm going to be okay.
Do you know I mean?
I couldn't even to begin to,
I think coming from immigrant
background and things of that
nature like my perspective
is on fucking point.
I'm very aware of how awesome
it is so, yeah,
it's a lot of pressure.
Great, so then don't do it.
Sell the company, downsize it.
I've made it's like I like want
to instill that on
the rest of the org.
You're a big girl.
Whatever problems the biggest
reason I'm giving you this
little rant is I want you to
know that if you ever have
anything, I'm here.
- [Jocelyn] Mhmmm.
- Like email me.
- [Jocelyn] Okay.
- You know?
Have you met Claude yet?
- [Jocelyn] I haven't.
- You have to
email her, right now.
- [Jocelyn] Okay.
- I'm forcing you.
- You have to go to
your desk and email her.
And be like I want her
to know who you are.
This horse shit,
it's way more real
than you think.
- [Jocelyn] Mhmmm.
- Take advantage of it.
You stumbled into it,
fucking take advantage of it.
- [Jocelyn] Okay.
- Do you understand?
- [Jocelyn] Yeah. I'll do that.
Email Claude, email Steve.
- You know?
- [Jocelyn] Mhmmm.
- It's good and you should
get the most benefit from it.
- [Jocelyn] I will.
- Cool.
- [Jocelyn] Yeah.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
Have a great day.
(light music)